[Musik]
der soll ja lobbyarbeit betrieben haben
und dafür aktienoptionen bekommen mann
bzw einen direktorenposten hat er
mittlerweile zurückgegeben hat einen
fehler eingestanden ist die sache damit
erledigt das kann ich heute morgen so
kurz nach 8 in dieser woche nicht
bewerten weil er nicht weiß kommt dann
auch was und philipp alter glaube ich
muss ja zum beispiel noch erklären wer
hat die flugreisende zahl für die
übernachtung bezahlt welche
größenordnung hat das da sind noch ein
paar punkte offen und wir müssen in
dieser woche gespräche führen ist ein
junger mann das war nicht gerade klug
und clever was er da gemacht hat und wie
gesagt ich hoffe dass es bei dem bleibt
was jetzt offenkundig jetzt nicht klug
und clever sagen sie aber gab es an
klaren interessenkonflikt wurde man
nicht mehr in interessenkonflikten also
mir persönlich ich würde mich jetzt
nicht für eine us amerikanische firma
einsetzen ich würde mich immer für
firmen aus meinem wahlkreis einsetzen
das habe ich gemacht das mache ich auch
weiter hin und da deswegen habe ich
gesagt das war nicht sehr klug und sehr
clever was er gemacht hat an der stelle
haben sieben das selbst gesagt wir
hatten noch keine gelegenheit persönlich
zu sprechen wir werden das in diesem
auto also bekommt ein anpfiff
möglicherweise auch im land fleck können
sie mit ihrer erfahrung aus mecklenburg
vorpommern sagen wie das bei den
menschen dort ankommt weiterreisen
luxusreisen offenbar auf kosten
vermutlich nicht selbst bezahlt auf
kosten einer großen us start up firma
der mecklenburg vorpommern ist das land
mit dem mit einem der niedrigsten
durchschnittseinkommen in deutschland
und ich glaube aber dass das sind bayern
oder bei uns überhaupt nicht gut ankommt
wenn bundestagsabgeordnete so agieren
[Musik]